we often here as a sort of defense to
the entire Trump Russia scandal that
Trump hasn't actually done anything
favorable to be favorable to Russia
period and of course this is bogus going
all the way back to the days of the
Republican convention last summer where
Trump associates demanded that the RNC
change its policy to be softer against
Russia and there's numerous examples
since then but we have yet another
example of something the Trump
administration has done that's favorable
to Russia the Trump administration is
now planning to return to diplomatic
compounds to Russia one year New York
City and another on the eastern Maryland
Shore Russia's officials you might
remember were ejected from those Kunka
compounds in late December as a
punishment for Russian interference in
the 2016 presidential election as
confirmed by numerous intelligence
agencies President Barack Obama said on
December 29th that the compounds were
being used quote by Russian personnel
for intelligence related purposes and
gave Russia 24 hours to vacate them so
early last month the Trump
administration told the Russians that it
would consider turning the properties
back over to them if Moscow would lift
its freeze which was imposed in 2014 in
retaliation for American sanctions
related to Ukraine on the construction
of a new US consulate on a certain
parcel of land in st. Petersburg two
days later the u.s. position changed
then Secretary of State Rex Hill erson
told the Russian Foreign Minister Sergey
Lavrov as well as our buddy now it's
amazing how familiar we are now with the
name Sergey kiss lyac Sergey kiss Lea
also told by Rex Tillerson at a meeting
in Washington that the US had dropped
any kind of a linkage between the
compounds in the consulate before making
a final decision on allowing the
Russians back into these compounds the
administration is looking at possible
restrictions of Russian activities there
one possibility would be that they'd
remove diplomatic immunity previously
these two Russian compounds at
diplomatic immunity meaning that
American law enforcement would be barred
from entering they are maybe considering
not having diplomatic immunity when they
give the compounds back this isn't
exactly a great time to be making
concessions to Russia is it given that
the president and his administration are
under in
by the House Senate and a special
prosecutor for alleged ties to Russia no
but I also don't think that Trump
supporters are people who deny the Trump
Russia scandal are going to be too
convinced by this yeah but it certainly
does go to this idea of different
Putin kills people we have killers too
it's all the same
well Crimea I was thinking there they're
obviously not so obtuse that they're
missing that this could look bad I'm
sure they get that they simply don't
care and that's what's so unsettling
about this they're acting with total
impunity and there's another angle which
is in order to do this despite knowing
that it will look bad at least to some
people they must have more to gain by
doing this then making themselves look
bad in the midst of this investigation
they really don't think that Russia
poses a threat or that they haven't
committed atrocities like killing a
political opposition or reporters this
is actually more important than it
appears this was part of the punishment
that the Obama administration had pushed
for hacking the election they removed
spies they closed these facilities they
imposed sanctions that's as far as what
we know publicly we know that disgraced
former national security adviser Michael
Flynn at minimum had spoken with Russia
about removing the sanctions that were
imposed for hacking the election we also
know that Russia just threatened the
u.s. to adjust the punishment from the
election hack issued by the Obama
administration is this the opening of
the door to a more substantial lifting
of sanctions next and and that is why
you could say well listen this is just
undoing stuff Obama has done Obama did
this Trump didn't like it
Putin didn't respond in kind so we're
just going to lift it but when you look
at what the discussions were that
disgraced former National Security
Advisor Michael Flynn had had in terms
of substance with Sergei his lyac we're
starting to do the things that they had
talked about and that's why this paint
this broader picture which I think again
a lot of people are ideologically
committed to just ignoring and
pretending isn't going on it's also
possible that they had plans that fell
through because the public became aware
of this Trump Russia scandal right but
certainly they could do things like lift
the sanctions
recognize their annexation of Crimea and
maybe even an oil deal and that might
apply also to the entire back channel
that Jared Kushner we now know was
trying to establish we don't actually
know whether that was or wasn't
established because a lot of these
things started to go public and and the
heat sort of started to build but maybe
we'll find out one day support for the
David Pakman show and the following
message comes from Wonder Capital Wonder
capital's online investment platform
allows you to invest in solar energy
projects across the United States no
matter what your risk-return appetite
Wonder has you covered
each wonder solar fund is designed by
solar specialists with help from their
sophisticated underwriting algorithms
then each month your investment returns
will be seamlessly deposited directly
into your bank account you can earn up
to eight and a half percent annually
while also diversifying your portfolio
curbing pollution and combating global
climate change in fact investors like
you finance 40 large-scale solar
projects in 2016 offsetting the co2
emissions from 2.8 million pounds of
burned coal you can start investing with
as little as $1,000 and best of all
Wonder Capital doesn't charge any
investor fees to learn more create an
account for free at wonder capital
dot-com slash Pakman that's w un de r
capital dot-com /pa que ma n wonder
capital do well and do good